[Music]
so I mean your argument is that there's
been this long attempt to create a
realist version of language but if we
accept that everything is ineffable we
can't really intervene is that the so we
need a further theory some way as you
say that closure is a way otherwise we
just lost and we can't really do also
anything it's that is that am i preye
seeing insufficiently I'm sure but you
want to say in part I mean I mean the
the the the realist trope in a
philosophical sense has been you know
dominant for the last at least in North
America and the UK
you know since since Russell and Vikram
Stein overturned galleon ISM back in
that back in the turn of the 19th
century it's not so much that I think we
need a we need to bolster that theory
it's just that I think it it's failed I
mean there isn't a decent realist theory
that concerning the Tractatus came to
the conclusion that it's logically
impossible in terms of what I was
putting forward though and in context of
what jr. was saying later the concern I
see the proposal that I'm proposing in
terms of openness and closure as in a
way a response to what I see as being
the difficulties of the latest bit
constrain your position so it seemed to
me Mick and Stein abandoned the idea to
describe the relationship between
language in the world because he'd come
to the conclusion that tract isa said it
wasn't logically possible and in his
later work far from being able to say
everything he doesn't think that you can
say anything at all about the essential
nature of our predicament I what the
nature is between a rate and nature of
the relationship between language in the
world is at all so he avoids it so he's
constantly avoiding saying anything in
terms of an overall philosophical view
and and that seems to me to be a certain
sort of bad faith that the way that we
understand the later Wittgenstein is to
is to impute this view to him that we
are just all in a language game but he
can't quite say that because if we
imagine a ters there we are humans more
operating this language game were
somehow
trying to step outside of language and
say how it ultimately is so we have to
start and catch on to the fact that he's
trying to tell us something about what's
going on but he can't quite tell us and
and I can't buy this I think we do need
an overall framework which in a sense is
in the Vik continuum position of not
being able to have a realistic count of
language but which enables us to be able
to operate and function and the account
that I've indicated you have in terms of
thinking of the world as being open and
we provide closures which enable us to
intervene is an attempt to build that
sort of framework which is not a realist
framework it's not saying this is how it
automatically is it itself is a metaphor
it itself is a closure but I would
obviously advocate that it's got some
value and it helps us make sense of
where we are and it and you might find
it useful in the way you operate in the
world I'm gonna bring again here in a
moment on Viktor Tsoi I just wanted to
press you one more on one more question
so it's the premise then that in a way
it's a language game to divide things
into ineffable and effable as it were so
inexpressible in language and
expressible that that would that that's
almost a rearrangement of things in
relation to the possibility there is
something beyond but that's not adequate
so that almost everything's
inexpressible at one level but then we
can't do that yes I'm not sure I fully
understand your point that I mean this
is F abort this is ineffable or within a
closed system could you do that yes
well the vocabulary of openness
enclosure is trying to find some way to
get outside of the puzzle that of course
as soon as you refer to the inevitable
in some sense you can't because you've
actually just referred to into some yeah
something and therefore you've made it I
mean the first philosophical work I
wrote was called reflexivity and it's
exactly about that problem of self
reference so in a way it's trying to
find a solution to that and to say give
up on the idea that the world is
something in particular anything in
particular think of the world as being
open and we find ways to close it and of
course that applies to what I am saying
now
and to the theory that I'm for it it's a
way of closing the world and it helps us
intervene of course I'm not saying that
this is a new truth that would be absurd
but I do think we have to engage in
trying to create theories we have to try
and provide metaphors try and make sense
of where we are while recognizing that
they're never going to arrive thank you
would you come in on this question you
said nothing is inexpressible in
principle the victims dine in well
actually I'd like I'd like to say
something in response to you said about
bit constrain because I'm afraid I
completely disagree with virtually
everything you've said about it so on
the early MacKinnon I mean he didn't
think offering a theory that connects
language and world is is logically
impossible I mean he thought you can't
express it in propositions but but
language shows it and he still thought
he could talk quite a lot about what
can't be said and this is why he's got
the metaphor about throwing away the
ladder at the end I mean it obviously
ends in logical paradox who's presenting
a theory and then at the end saying well
actually this theory can't be expressed
so throw away the ladder after you've
climbed it and obviously that's hugely
unsatisfactory but but he did he did
think that he presented a true if
paradoxical are not actually in the end
state able theory but he did think he'd
captured something about what the
relation between language and the world
is no I just respond so so I just hold
it slightly differently of course we be
talking about the same key bits here and
whether victims time sort of held what
he was saying in the tract ages is being
true which is you're saying he presented
this as a true what he says in the
preface the truth the truth of these
thoughts seems to me unassailable and
definitive Simsbury but but you
so says at the end we have to throw it
away so those two are not compatible
he can't on the one hand be asserting it
as saying it is true and look this other
hand saying that he's throwing it away
so the way I read it cynically true is
is that he has he does as well as he can
to say how it is he thinks he's got the
best realist theory out there but he
concludes at the end but I can't do this
and as a result of that he abandons this
philosophical position in his later work
because he's come to the conclusion that
you can't do it so so that would be my
way of understanding that rather than
saying oh actually Viktor Stein was in
the position of believing that something
was true that he said is impossible well
just respond quickly well I mean he he
thought and you know I'm not saying that
this is a view that anyone should take
but at the time I think he was committed
to the thought that this was an
ineffable true theory can't be expressed
in propositions because propositions can
only state facts but nevertheless the
way he characterized the relation
between language and the world he
thought that was correct if it could be
captura below factual's then that's how
it would be but but obviously that's
that's a huge problem and he did change
his mind but actually I think weirdly
enough he didn't change his mind because
of that problem he changed his mind
because of the color exclusion problem
he changed his mind because he thought
it's no longer correct that elementary
propositions are independent of each
other but that might lead us to too far
afield to thank you for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute of Arts and ideas at III
TV
you